oh my god the story about a girl who was
she went into a porta potti and she
thought she saw something like when
she's sitting down and then she realized
like she heard like groans she realized
there was some guy in there inside the
Porta Potty just laying there watching
this [ __ ] come out and hitting him in
the head was mouth open while she's
[ __ ] and pissing on him oh my god
climbed in to the [ __ ] and piss that is
so disgusting and hot at the same time
for some reason the fact that a monster
would lay there like that he's probably
a [ __ ] snorkel porta potty peeper
Luke Christo suing Boulder for ninety
nine thousand nine hundred and
ninety-nine dollars or equal amount of
gold coinage
he's from Boulder Colorado he's suing
Boulder or he's so it happened in
Bertram Boulder yeah yeah boulders a
trippy place man people been getting
really high in Boulder for a long time
and there's no air up there so if you
get super baked in Boulder like you you
could blow a fuse look at that porta
potty it's like built for that it looks
like it's like a float tank you know
it's like it's like one of those
first-class seats you get when you fly
to Australia oh yeah it says what yeah
hold on Crisco has made his mark on the
internet under a variety of monikers
including Omni rainbow and sky or yon
whose YouTube channel features clips
including this one in which he
demonstrates his thigh rubbing technique
yeah I wonder why
it's been pulled from the internet so
this is the guy so he was he climbed in
there to have people [ __ ] on him yeah
and how did he know that there was a
girl his reward for susta patient's was
a sight of a slender black haired white
man what wait a minute don't scroll what
are you going I didn't know what the
hell they were talking about but I'm
reading that go back a slender sweat
black haired white man standing between
6:45 and six foot eight inches tall with
cuts on his back and arms wearing only a
pair of sweatpants what is this about
oh so this is the security guard
realized that he was doing something
scroll back up so let's do that imagine
like waiting there under the toilet in
the Porta Potty for a hot chick to come
in and just like Joey Diaz comes in like
June 2011 we know that a woman attended
the Hammond festival stepped into a
portable laboratory in which she lifted
totes lid she saw something moving in
the deep dark depths below cue shocked
car and quick escape was she fetched a
man and asked him to look inside he too
saw some movement beneath a tarp inside
the tank and after exiting the chamber
he heard the door locked behind them at
that point he summoned the security okay
that's what happened and then they
caught that guy so he's in there with a
tarp hiding under a tarp while people
are [ __ ] on him look at his face is
that the mug shot is there [ __ ] all over
him oh God
son of a [ __ ] yeah it's like the it
clown meets the [ __ ] clown
oh look at this he sat down with Fox 31
for a jailhouse interview in which he
referred to spying on urinating or
defecating women in quotes the highest
creature in the universe he maintained
as in quotes praising God and said in
quotes it sounds kind of weird but I
would just find my piece and go away say
thank you goddess and go about my night
Wow isn't that the scariest part when
you when you drop a deuce in the toilet
you hear the words thank you God thank
you guys for your offerings
other people's in other places around
Boulder also just serve restaurants just
to know that someone like that is a real
person like you have to realize we
sometimes you have to see someone like
that to go okay I don't know everybody
there's there's a there's a long range
you know if there's a chart of like
[ __ ] up to like totally nor
yeah there's a lot of variables in there